[Music]
bill Potter
we went down to Sony's offices in London
the other day to check out the
PlayStation classic yeah very excited
about that and what we thought we'd do
is compare it to another retro console
which came out last year the snez
classic obviously they've both got an
inbuilt collection of games that you'll
probably remember from your childhood
but what did you think about the the
places in classic which we should say at
this stage we although we got an hour or
so of hands-on with it it it was not the
final version or at least it may not be
final so things could change but from
what we saw one played what does it feel
like what does it look like what did it
smell like bill it smell like my
playstation from when I was a kid well I
didn't get a good sniff but initial
impressions are really good actually
right off the bat I felt like this was a
great nostalgia package like as soon as
you switch it on you press that little
power button on this tiny cute little
console and it felt like you're back in
the 90s with that classic startup sound
that sounds so good yeah
it filled the room with that noise it's
a surrogate and right away yeah it feels
very similar to how the snez Classic was
set up in that you've got a snappy quick
menu with all of those games to cycle
through and you can just get straight in
to playing your favorite games it
essentially it works the same way and
it's a virtual kind of library of games
that and it will also create virtual
save files for you on virtual memory
cards and even like one of the most
strange little details about it the
eject button is not an actual so it
doesn't lift the flap up like it would
on an original may station because
obviously there's no actual disk drive
but some games if they needed to disks
back in the day then you need to eject
the virtual disk and put the other
virtual disk in that is weird
but like it is a nice touch at the same
time I will miss the fact that IO missed
them being able to lift the flap up and
see the disk spinning around because I
used to love doing that when I was a kid
yeah but it works the same way in the
snows classic in that way yeah I love
that they've added these quirky little
details to make it feel a bit more like
that original experience similar to the
snares mini for example which has
details like that the first thing I did
with the PlayStation was go to the
settings to see what the display options
are because the great thing about the
snooze classic was you could have four
by three you could have a pixel perfect
mode where it has pixels as precise
square so everything looks a bit sharper
and it also had a CRT mode so you have
sort of like lions it looked a bit more
like what it would have on an old TV and
I didn't see anything like that on the
PlayStation so I think it's straight
just like here's the game emulated but
overall yeah it felt like they've been
very much influenced by the snez classic
and brought a similar nostalgia
experience to the PlayStation just in
time for Christmas but physically at
least it does seem to be well I don't
know the contest always clearly scaled
down tiny yeah but the is around the
same sort of size as the snow's classic
I would say but the controllers are a
one-to-one replica of the original
PlayStation controllers as well
unfortunately they're not
DualShock so they don't have notice Lee
Rumble and they don't have the sticks as
well which I'm gonna miss the
controllers did feel good and we
compared them with the original place
they should controllers and they were
pretty much identical like as far as I
could tell they were exactly the same
form factor they felt just as good the
cable length was not that long yeah it
was maybe what three or four feet
something like that like you you're not
gonna be able to if you've got a big
living room you're not gonna be able to
sit on your sofa no and and and play at
a distance which is what I ended up
doing with my snares was sitting on the
floor did you yeah with just as many on
the floor from my TV or buying what I've
done for the snooze classic is buying a
wireless controller from a third party
right which may be a thing with the
PlayStation we yeah yeah yeah yeah be
interesting to see if there are any
third-party things another thing that I
found odd actually was like having to
lean forward and press the reset button
or the off button I'm so you know now to
to just hold press on the PlayStation
button on my ps4 right and just turn it
off so having to lean forward and it's
the same with the snares you know they
have replicated it one to one there as
well yeah that's true I mean you could
argue that's part of the nostalgia
experience like being a kid again with
this tiny little console on the floor
sat right up close to your TV but then
again like it's not very convenient so
it's a bit annoying yeah but yeah I
think all together I think they're both
very very good replicants is that the
word replicas they're very good replicas
they've like very good androids they're
both very good replicas of the original
consoles that they're trying to emulate
yeah
[Music]
now obviously bill the most important
thing about any console is the games
that you can play on it now
the PlayStation classic lineup has
disappointed some people out there who
feel that there are big games missing
stuff like Spyro trilogy Crash Bandicoot
Tomb Raider what are your thoughts given
given that the snares classic really
does have the greatest hits of that
console do you think the PlayStation
classic lineup is is a little bit
disappointing or do you think it's got a
sufficient amount of nostalgia and good
games there I don't think I could say
that it does you know I think a lot of
people were speculating before they
announced the full list of what was
coming to the PlayStation Classic and
yeah I think the general feeling is it's
quite disappointing like you've got some
great games on there like Metal Gear
Solid's Resident Evil the original grand
theft auto's there's some goods
PlayStation classics
wow what a mansion stop it don't open
that door but when you look at what's
been missed out on the PlayStation
Classic I'm gonna have to pull out a
list for this so that bad surely but
there's things like Gran Turismo
Castlevania Symphony of the Night crash
and Spyro like you said Tomb Raider
parappa the rapper wipeouts Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater to me that was like a classic
PlayStation game Ape Escape Dino Crisis
there are so many there and I don't
think you could look at the snez classic
in the same way because it really is
almost a complete package of the best
games that released on that system well
not only that but it also comes with
Star Fox 2 which is yeah unreleased at
the time yeah so it actually comes it's
a complete plus one it was the
PlayStation lineup is very clearly
missing some big games and and you know
they're not saying why those games are
missing but I would imagine is this
probably has something to do with the
fact that Activision have obviously
remastered crash and Spyro of their own
accord recently as for Tomb Raider and
all the other ones you listed there I
don't know but I think having played
them and seen the complete lineups is
it's hard to argue that PlayStation has
as good a lineup as the snares lineup
but what about actually playing them and
do you think that playing the games that
are on the snow's classic and on the
PlayStation classic do you think they
hold up today or do you think they're
showing their age a little bit at this
point yeah that's another case where I
think the snez does sort of Trump the
PlayStation as well even though that's a
more recent system I think that error of
games where that low poly look can be
quite charming I don't think it does age
as well on the whole as the snez mmm
that classic snez 16-bit look is
timeless like some of those games you
can play today and they look as good as
ever it's like they haven't aged
[Music]
and a lot of indie games a lot of games
released today are looking like those
classic games because it's like it still
looks good and I saw you trying to play
some of the PlayStation games and not
having the best of times what are you
saying about my gaming ability hell not
that at all it's just it's it's very
different playing those games today it's
very different yeah I was trying to play
a bit of Rainbow six and trying to play
a first-person shooter without sticks
yeah
baffles my mind they was really
difficult and I know I'm gonna sound so
incompetent when they say that but it
was it's so different now it's been you
know 15 years since you've had to do
that really maybe 20 so it does sort of
take some getting used to whereas I
think like you say that this knows
classic the style of game that it has
you know there's a lot of 2d platformers
we were playing a bit of Donkey Kong
Country just just now and like that
feels as good now as tropical freeze
does on the switch you know it's like I
think the style of game that the cenotes
classic has is probably like you say
more timeless and less dated than the
style of game that the PlayStation has
yeah for sure and I just think like
although the PlayStation Classic is a
nice little package it's missing so much
you can't really ignore that and at the
end of it you do feel a bit disappointed
that you're spending more than you did
on the snows classic and not having as
many of those Alzheimer's it doesn't
feel like a complete of representation
of the PlayStation to me to me it misses
to many of those huge titles that were
so iconic back then that to me it just
feels
underbaked and I think yeah what for
whatever reason that they couldn't get
those games on there I think that's
going to be the big downfall of the
system and we did ask are there any
plans to introduce maybe you know
downloadable titles further down the
line and and they said currently that
there are no plans to do that so you
know
it's not looking as if you're gonna be
able to buy you know Crash Bandicoot for
five pounds or five dollars six months
time and download it you know the same
as the snails in that regard you know
that's that's it it's those games and
that's your lot
so I mean you guys make your mind up and
see which lineup you prefer
[Music]
all right bill holiday season is coming
up a lot of presents are gonna be bought
a lot of presents are gonna be unwrapped
if I were to be buying you a present
this holiday season which one would you
want to be unwrapping that's very nice
of you I think while both systems are
very good bits of hardware they have the
look and feel just right mm-hmm
it does come down to the games I think
for me I'd have more fun on the stairs
classic is that because of the lineup of
games that it and not necessarily
whether or not they play better on those
systems but it's just simply a case of
the snares lineup is better than the
PlayStation lineup yeah hundred cent I
think there's more on this in this
classic that I'd look forward to playing
whereas the PlayStation Classic there
are some good games I love I'm a huge
Metal Gear Solid fan for example yeah
but there's not enough there that I feel
like I'd you know get as much fun out of
the snez so that's why I'd go for the
snez over the PlayStation yeah I think
I'd have to agree like even though I was
a PlayStation boy like growing up the
games that I played on PlayStation on on
the PlayStation classic so you know I
was I was cycling through the list
yesterday and there's not a lot there
really there excites me there's a lot of
classic games but it's not the ones that
I played it as a youngster and so the
snez wins this one hands down for me
[Music]
alright guys that was our thoughts on
the PlayStation Classic and how it
compares to the snez classic let us know
your thoughts on the two consoles and
whether or not you're planning on buying
a PlayStation Classic in the comments
section below or you can find us on
Twitter I'm out there said I'm at the
quiff is dead and we'll see you next
time
[Music]